usager des bus entre Versailles et véisy
voilà qui pourrait améliorer votre
quotidien le 1er novembre dernier 80
véhicules du réseau ont été dotés d'un
vaporisateur de parfum à chaque fois que
les portes s'ouvrent et se referment
celui-ci entre en action nous avons
effectivement l'objectif de rendre plus
agréable le transport entre véisie et
Versailles et sur l'ensemble du réseau
de véisie afin que nos voyageurs
puissent passer du temps euh dans une
ambiance sereine et aimable c'est une
initiative des conducteurs de bus elle
répond aussi au nouveaux critères du
Grand Paris visant à rendre les
transports en commun plus confortables
les usagers quant à eux sont ravis je
prends le bus tous les jours et c'est
vrai que ça fait du bien de de sentir
autre chose que le l'odeur de de tout le
monde le matin ou des choses comme ça
mais au fait de quel parfum s'agit-il
baptiser lagagon le produit diffuse des
senteurs marines pour créer un sentiment
d'évasion revendique la société
gestionnaire du réseau pas sûr que tout
le monde s'y retrouve ça ressemble à la
mè ça fa pens à ça non pas trop je vois
pas du tout à quoi ça pourrait me faire
penser c'est arrivé que c'était boisé
enfin
ou fleuris des odeurs florales encore à
côté je sais pas ce que c'est exactement
ça fait plus penser à la mer ou les
ouais je dirais ça à la mer enfin une
bonne réponse si l'expérience est
approuvée par une majorité d'usagers ce
sont d'autres lignes des réseaux de
vélzy et de saint-cy qui seront équipés